I think if you're not scared that
somebody can hurt you because you have
your own self-esteem you'll practice
intuition more attention is the number
one asset do you think everyone has
intuition I think everyone has intuition
I think there's levels to it I think
everybody can play basketball I don't
know like all four of us in the room
right now could go outside play
basketball yeah my intuition on that is
we will not look like the New York
Knicks that play at Marden no matter how
bad of a basketball team they are they
are dramatically better than the four of
us I think a lot of people have been
told not to believe in intuition which
means they haven't practiced intuition I
think a lot of people are scared to get
hurt so they don't go under intuition
because when they have in the past
somebody hurt them and they're scared to
get hurt again um I think there's a lot
that goes into intuition but for me
intuition is everything I think there's
a direct correlation to intuition and
self-esteem okay so I think it takes
risk to follow your intuition and I
think if you're not scared that somebody
can hurt you because you have your own
self-esteem you'll practice intuition
more